now trump 2020 senior adviser mercedes
schlapp mercedes great to see you today
we heard
over an hour from the president we had
behind that
comments by joe biden as well and now
they head to pennsylvania
the fever pitch is all about what will
happen on election day
tell me about what the president is
planning to do he says he's sending in
the lawyers
well obviously the president wants a
fair and free
election we want to protect election
integrity we want to make sure
that there's one vote per voter that
will count
and uh you know obviously our growing
concern is that we're starting to see
these democrats panic in the sense that
uh we're cutting into their early voting
uh they it seems like they don't have
enough democrats out there that are
going to vote in person on election day
because they've spent a lot a lot of
time creating
fear and telling people don't vote in
person
on the republican side and on president
trump's side our voters are going to go
out on election day
there is a huge strong ground game on
our side
and so we're making sure that our voters
get out to vote
and so i think at this point what you're
starting to see and what we have seen
is that you see these democrats are
looking to cut ads they're they're
prepping their surrogates with talking
points questioning
election integrity looking to loosen the
rules
in these different states and that's
troublesome for
for for us and it's why we're going to
make sure that we're legally prepared
to take on these challenges all right
real quickly you started off with making
sure that one vote gets counted as one
vote
did it frustrate the process to have the
president of the united states suggest
on the stump recently
that you could change your vote if
you've already voted
well i think that's different uh of
changing your vote
as opposed to what you don't want to
encounter is a situation of voter fraud
where
someone is voting how would you do that
if you've already voted though
well i think that there's state
requirements for a different state so if
someone
wanted to change a vote or not change a
vote that's different than
going and trying to vote twice in
essence or trying to for example
in the case of you have in many of these
cases which you see with mail and voting
where someone receives a ballot that
doesn't even live in that address or
they've received two or three different
live ballots that they receive at one
address
that's where we see more potential for
complications and voter fraud when it
comes to uh
in different states we see that you see
that in cases like
in nevada where you've seen voters
receive multiple ballots
to one address although that they might
have moved from that address and so
that's where you see these complications
happen
all right i want to move on to something
that the president did touch on on the
stump today
but wow the u.s reporting more than 99
000 new coronavirus cases on friday the
highest single day number
of new infections of any other nation
recorded the president last night
suggested he may
dismiss dr anthony fauci from the white
house coronavirus task force
after the election let's watch
[Applause]
don't tell anybody but let me wait till
a little bit after the election
so mercedes some of the good news that
the president has
talked about is the vaccine and possibly
by the end of the year and his plan to
roll that out
um for at least getting it out there
most people wouldn't get it until the
second quarter of next year according to
the experts
dr fauci though very respected figure
and and i'm wondering
especially for some of the swing voters
so they say
who was the president trying to reach
with the message that he will fire
fouchy well i think that uh fauci's
comments this past weekend were
disappointing i mean he played politics
and when you're a career employee and
you're there to serve the american
people
you want to stay out of the politics
you're there to provide medical advice
as opposed to
take a political side so i think for the
president as we know fauci is one of his
many medical experts
that are advising the president and as
we know the president
has listened to his medical experts in
the past it's why he took
bold and aggressive actions especially
in the beginning
when he put in travel restrictions to
china we know that
joe biden responded to that by calling
that xenophobic
and so it's president trump's strong
actions that have saved millions of
lives
joe biden on the other hand he's
plagiarizing our plan he doesn't have a
plan of his own he just wants to make
sure that we all wear a mask
and and put a national mask mandate
locked down this
country which we know we cannot afford
we need to reopen our schools reopen our
economy
safely and responsibly and get americans
back to work
the long-term lockdown strategy of joe
biden
is ineffective will not work and be
destructive to our nation
yeah you know the president is still the
president right now and as we lead the
world
uh in a place where we never thought
we'd be in terms of cases
even admiral gerard hand-picked by the
president of the united states says
it's not because we're over testing a
complicated space for all of us as
americans to be and mercedes thank you
very much
appreciate your time thank you so